Meta reasoning arguably is one of the most critical process of
the human cognition. In fact, some researchers suggest that,
developing meta-cognative skills at an early age in life,
may be the best predictor of a student success later in life. Actually,
this makes sense. Meta reasoning is not about simply learning new information,
it is about learning how to learn. About, learning new reasoning strategies.
About integrating new information into memory structures. Meta reasoning is
also connected to creativity. In meta reasoning, the agent is monitoring its
own reasoning. It is spawning goals. It is trying to achieve them.
Sometimes it suspends a goal, sometimes it abandons a goal. These are all part
of the creative process. Creativity is not just about creating new products.
It is also about creating a processes, that lead to interesting products.